This is a super interesting peek behind the
curtain.
There are now multiple reports out that privately
Donald Trump junior believes that Donald Trump
is going to lose in November and lose badly.
And fascinatingly, Don Junior reportedly believes
that not only Donald Trump but Don Junior
and maybe other members of the family are
going to be indicted and prosecuted.
If Donald Trump loses loses in November.
This is so interesting in terms of what it
says about their realization about what's
going on, despite always claiming everything
is great.
So The New York Times is an interesting piece
about this, where they quote a prominent conservative
activist who was interviewed on the condition
of anonymity, who told The New York Times
that Don Junior thinks they're going to lose
in November and that when they lose, they're
going to get, quote, really hurt.
Meaning that federal prosecutions of not just
Donald Trump, but of his family and political
allies may be an inevitability.
And according to the same conservative activists,
Don Junior believes that a Biden administration
will not peacefully transition, but they will
instead shoot the prisoners was the term that
Don Junior used, although that particular
piece was later denied by Andy Sarabia, who's
another Republican operative.
So there's a few different things here.
First, let's deal with the prosecution.
You could say if you're innocent, you don't
fear being prosecuted.
That's fair.
But it's really easy to counter in this particular
case, because if you believe that there will
be politically motivated partizan political
attacks, you could take the position that
the next administration will prosecute you,
not because you committed crimes, but as political
payback.
Now, there's, of course, no evidence of that.
If Joe Biden wins and there are prosecutions
of the Trump family, it would be because there's
evidence that they committed crimes, not because
of some personal vendetta by Joe Biden.
But for me, the more important revelation
is about Donald Trump's desperation to win.
If Don Junior really believes that there is
a risk of prosecution, if Joe Biden wins in
November, that must be at least somewhat in
Donald Trump's mind, at least a little bit.
And it would explain Donald Trump's willingness
to do anything to win in November.
And we've talked about this before.
Donald Trump may genuinely believe that he
must win in November to avoid prosecution.
I actually don't think it's likely.
I think the Trump organization will be gone
after for financial crimes and it won't touch
Trump personally.
But if Trump thinks it's a possibility, he
is like a cornered animal.
That's the analogy we've been using.
And cornered animals behave erratically.
That tells us why Trump will use the post
office and try to suppress vote by mail and
try to close polling places and contests the
election results and call it rigged and welcome
foreign interference.
Because Trump may see this not just as fighting
for his political life and his reputation
as he may see it, but as the way to keep himself
out of prison or at least out of a courtroom
for the rest of his life.
Now, just imagine, for the sake of following
this, imagine if Biden wins and makes Hillary
Clinton attorney general.
And imagine that she oversees prosecution
of the Trump family when it was Trump in 2016
running on lock her up.
I don't deny that there would be something
interesting about that.
But let's put it aside here and not really
put the cart before the horse.
The real takeaway is that a quarter cornered
animal will lash out in ways that are incredibly
dangerous and violent.
And that's what we have to expect over the
next 10 weeks here.
It is 10 weeks to the day today until November
3rd.
Now, my real concern is that Trump won't lose
in November and that I can't exactly put my
finger on it.
But over the last two weeks, I've started
to lean closer to thinking a Trump reelection
is more likely than it was a couple of weeks
ago.
Polling might be a part of it.
Polling is certainly tightened a little bit.
In late June, Biden was averaging plus 10
nationally.
Now Biden is averaging plus seven point five.
So that's part of it.
But there's something intangible that I can't
quite put my finger on that has me more worried
today about a Trump reelection than I was
two to three weeks ago.
We know what you think it might be.
We'll have more on this on The David Pakman
Show Instagram page at The David Pakman Show.
While you're there, follow me on Instagram
at David Pakman.
The David Pakman Show.
David Pakman dot com.